aussi loin que je me souvienne j'ai
toujours voulu chanter
seulement voilà tout le monde ne met pas
le son de ma voix autant que ma mère
c'était de toute évidence un drame sans
fin plein de musiques et de violences un
peu comme un opéra l'opéra de ma vie ta
copine ça va être intention de bouger
pour la rencontrer un jour ou pas elle
ressemble à 90 ans attends tu as dit que
tu ressemblais à quelqu'un de célèbre
toi aussi vaguement oui je savais que
j'avais une passion pour l'opéra mais
alors là je pensais pas qu'on était
aussi dingue et on y colle à venise
j'économise pour y aller qui ne tente
rien n'a rien
jean t n o placé à la ville que du
public vous ne verrez pas si vous n'avez
pas l'otage de la vie si vous manquez
d'assurance
benoît n'êtes pas prêt pour sortait de
l'eau pas là et peut-être jamais tu l'as
eu des grandes aventures
m'est avis et c'est la maman tu vois moi
tu sais pourquoi tu es sur terre c'est
vrai d'un talent inné pour le chant je
crois que les seules fois où je suis
vraiment heureux c'est quand j'écoute ou
je chante de l'opéra c'est quoi ça un
concours de talent et qui dort
vous choisi de faire chanter de legrand
si vous voulez
peut être vraiment fier de toi